>>> WE ARE GETTING THIS DONE.
THANK YOU.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN UP ON CAPITOL
HILL TODAY TELLING DEMOCRATIC
SENATORS YOU JUST HEARD HIM SAY
IT, WE'RE GOING TO GET THIS
DONE.
AFTER LAWMAKERS ANNOUNCED A DEAL
ON A 3 1/2 TRILLION DOLLARS
SPENDING PACKAGE.
LET'S GO BACK TO OUR CHIEF WHITE
HOUSE CORRESPONDENT KAITLAN
COLLINS, SHE'S JOINING US ALONG
WITH CNN CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT RYAN NOBLES.
YOU HAVE NEW DETAILS EMERGING
RIGHT NOW ABOUT WHAT'S ACTUALLY
IN THIS NEW BUDGET PACKAGE THAT
SENATE DEMOCRATS HAVE AGREED ON.
WHAT ARE YOU LEARNING?
>> YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT.
AND THERE'S A LOT OF OPTIMISM
AMONG DEMOCRATS ABOUT THIS
$3.5 TRILLION PACKAGE, BUT
THERE'S A LONG WAY TO GO BEFORE
IT ENDS UP ON PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
DESK, IN PART BECAUSE WE DON'T
KNOW SPECIFICALLY WHAT'S GOING
TO BE IN IT.
SO FAR THESE BUDGET NEGOTIATORS
JUST RELEASING TOP LINE CONCEPTS
THAT THEY WANT TO INCLUDE, WHICH
ARE KEY PRIORITIES FOR MANY
DEMOCRATS, AMONG THEM, SOME
MAJOR INVESTMENTS IN FIGHTING
CLIMATE CHANGE, ALSO INVESTMENTS
IN THINGS LIKE UNIVERSAL PRE-K,
PAID FAMILY AND MEDICAL LEVER,
AS WELL AS CHILD CARE,
INVESTMENT IN HOUSING, SMALL
BUSINESS SUPPORT, AND AMERICAN
MANUFACTURING, AND THERE'S ALSO
GOING TO BE SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
TO THE TAX CODE.
WE DON'T KNOW THE SPECIFICS
BEHIND THIS EITHER, AND BASED ON
WHAT WE'RE HEARING DEMOCRATS
SAY, THIS MEANS TAX INCREASES ON
THE WEALTHIEST AMERICANS AND
CORPORATIONS, THAT'S BEEN A KEY
PRIORITY, ESPECIALLY FOR THESE
PROGRESSIVE MEMBERS OF BOTH THE
HOUSE AND SENATE WHO HAVE BEEN
PUSHING FOR THIS BIG PACKAGE.
$3.5 MILLION IS A LOT OF MONEY.
PROGRESSIVES WANTED TO SPEND AS
MUCH AS 6 TRILLION.
THEY HAVE BEEN OPEN TO FINDING
OUT MORE ABOUT THIS PACKAGE.
THE BIG QUESTION IS HOW MUCH IS
GOING TO BE SPENT IN EACH ONE OF
THE AREAS.
THEY SEEM TO BE RECEPTIVE OF THE
PACKAGE IN THE EARLY OFFERING.
>> KAITLAN, THE PRESIDENT
RETURNED TO CAPITOL HILL TO MAKE
THE SELL, TO RALLY SUPPORT AMONG
DEMOCRATS.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING?
HOW DID IT GO?
>> PUBLICLY HE SAID IT'S GOOD TO
BE HOME.
HE SPENT THREE DECADES ON
CAPITOL HILL AS A SENATOR.
WE KNOW FROM OUR REPORTING
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS, HE WAS
URGING THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO
STAY UNITED ON THIS PROCESS.
WE KNOW THEY ARE TRYING TO MOVE
QUICKLY.
THEY WOULD LIKE TO GET THIS DONE
BY AUGUST.
THAT IS GOING TO BE A
SIGNIFICANT HAUL FOR THE
DEMOCRAT LAWMAKERS ON CAPITOL
HILL AND FOR THE WHITE HOUSE
BEING INVOLVED IN THAT, AND SO
THAT WAS HIS MAIN MESSAGE TODAY
WAS TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE UNIFIED ON THIS BECAUSE
WE KNOW WHEN IT COMES TO THE
$3.5 TRILLION AGREEMENT, THERE
ARE PROGRESSIVE MEMBERS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS THAT WANTED IT
TO BE HIGHER, AND MODERATES WHO
WANTED IT TO BE A LOT LOWER, AND
THEY CANNOT AFFORD TO MISS A
SINGLE VOTE ON THIS, AS THEY ARE
ALSO TRYING TO SUBSEQUENTLY GET
THE BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE
DEAL PASSED, THE AGREEMENT, ONE
THAT HE WAS TRYING TO SELL TO A
GROUP OF THE NATION'S MAYORS,
AND GOVERNORS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE, AND HE DOES FEEL IT NEEDS
TO BE A TWO TRACK PROCESS?
>> KAITLAN COLLINS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE, RYAN NOBLES ON CAPITOL
HILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S GET MORE ON WHAT'S GOING
ON.
THE INDEPENDENT SENATOR BERNIE
SANDERS OF VERMONT IS JOINING
US, THE CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE
BUDGET COMMITTEE.
SENATOR, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US, AS YOU JUST HEARD,
AND AS YOU WOULD KNOW A LOT
BETTER THAN I DO, THIS IS, WHAT,
SOME 2 1/2 TRILLION DOLLARS LESS
THAN YOU AND MANY OF YOUR FELLOW
PROGRESSIVES INITIALLY WANTED.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THOSE FELLOW
PROGRESSIVES WHO FEEL THAT MAYBE
YOU GAVE IN TOO EASILY RIGHT
NOW?
>> WELL, WHAT I WOULD SAY, WOL,
NUMBER ONE, WE ARE IN FACTLOOKI
CONSEQUENTIAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION FOR WORKING FAMILIES
SINCE THE GREAT DEPRESSION, SO
THIS IS A VERY BIG, BIG DEAL,
WHICH IS GOING TO TRANSFORM THE
LIVES OF MANY MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS.
SECOND OF ALL WHAT I WOULD
SIMPLY SAY IS I WISH, YOU KNOW,
THAT THE REST OF THE SENATE HELD
MY POLITICAL VIEWS, BUT THEY
DON'T.
AS I THINK RYAN MENTIONED,
KAITLAN MENTIONED, THERE ARE 50
OF US IN THE SENATE, SOME MORE
CONSERVATIVES THAN OTHERS, AND
WE HAVE TO REACH AN AGREEMENT,
BUT ESSENTIALLY WHAT THE
FRAMEWORK OF THIS BILL IS ABOUT
IS NUMBER ONE, TELLING THE
WEALTHIEST PEOPLE IN THE LARGEST
CORPORATIONS, MANY OF WHOM HAVE
AVOIDED PAYING THEIR FAIR SHARE
OF TAXES, THOSE DAYS ARE OVER.
THEY'RE GOING TO START PAYING
THEIR FAIR SHARE OF TAXES.
SECOND.
>> GO AHEAD, MAKE YOUR SECOND
POINT.
>> SECOND OF ALL, WORKING
FAMILIES IN THIS COUNTRY WHILE
THE RICH ARE GETTING MUCH
RICHER, WORKING FAMILIES ARE
STRUGGLING.
THEY CAN'T AFFORD HEALTH CARE,
THEY CAN'T AFFORD CHILD CARE,
THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO SEND THEIR
KIDS TO COLLEGE.
THEY CAN'T AFFORD HOME HEALTH
CARE FOR THEIR PARENTS, AND WE
ARE GOING THROUGH IT IN A VERY
SIGNIFICANT WAY ADDRESS MANY OF
THESE CRISES THAT WORKING
FAMILIES ARE FACING, AND
THIRDLY, FINALLY, THE UNITED
STATES WILL LEAD THE WORLD IN
DEALING WITH ENORMOUS THREAT TO
OUR COUNTRY AND THE PLANET IN
TERMS OF CLIMATE CHANGE, AND
WHEN WE DO ALL OF THESE THINGS,
WE'RE GOING TO CREATE MANY MANY
MILLIONS OF GOOD PAYING JOBS
WHICH WE DESPERATELY NEED.
>> AS YOU KNOW, YOUR DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES, SENATOR JOE MANCHIN
OF WEST VIRGINIA, HE'S A PIVOTAL
VOTE IN ALL OF THIS.
IT'S A 50/50 SENATE.
HE'S VERY DISTURBED BY
PROVISIONS IN THE DEAL, HE
BELIEVES THAT WOULD ELIMINATE
FOSSIL FUELS, THAT'S A POINT
YOU'RE MAKING.
ARE THOSE PROVISIONS ON THE
TABLE IF IT MEANS GETTING MAN
CHIN TO SUPPORT THE WHOLE
PACKAGE.
>> LET ME TELL YOU, WHEN YOU'RE
DEALING WITH A BILL AS BIG AS
THIS, AND WITH 50 SENATORS FROM
STATES ALL OVER THE COUNTRY, A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE DISTURBING
ABOUT A LOT OF THINGS.
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT HAS
TO BE DONE.
BUT MY OWN VIEW IS CLIMATE
CHANGE, I MEAN, WE'RE SEEING
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE WEST
COAST OF THIS COUNTRY RIGHT
THOUSAND.
AND EVERYTHING BEING EQUAL, IF
WE DON'T GET OUR ACT TOGETHER
AND TRANSFORM OUR ENERGY SYSTEM,
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING ON THE WEST
COAST, WHAT YOU'RE SEEING
FLOODING IN DETROIT, IN NEW
YORK, IT'S ONLY GOING TO GET
WORSE.
SO WE HAVE TO BECOME VERY
AGGRESSIVE ABOUT COMBATTING
CLIMATE CHANGE, OBVIOUSLY WE
HAVE TO WORK WITH ALL 50
DEMOCRATIC SENATORS TO PASS THIS
BILL.
>> HOVERING OVER ALL OF THIS
RIGHT NOW IS THE FEAR OF
INFLATION, AS YOU WELL KNOW, THE
FEDERAL RESERVE CHAIRMAN
ADDRESSED DEEP CONCERNS ABOUT
HIGH INFLATION READINGS GOING ON
RIGHT NOW, AND INFLATION IS A
REALLY SERIOUS PROBLEM, NOT SO
MUCH FOR THE RICH, BUT FOR THE
MIDDLE CLASS AND THE POOR.
GASOLINE COSTS $4 A GALLON OR $5
A GALLON.
RICH PEOPLE DON'T CARE BUT
MIDDLE CLASS PEOPLE DO CARE.
HOW CONCERNED ARE YOU RIGHT NOW,
SENATOR, ABOUT INFLATION?
>> WELL, I AM CONCERNED ABOUT
INFLATION AMONG MANY OTHER
THINGS.
AS I THINK YOU KNOW, THIS BILL,
THIS 3 1/2 TRILLION, AND THEN
THERE'S ANOTHER 600 BILL IN A SO
CALLED BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL WILL PAY FOR ITSELF.
IT WILL BE PAID FOR IN A VARIETY
OF WAYS, BUT SIGNIFICANTLY BY
HIGHER TAXES ON THE WEALTHY AND
LARGE CORPORATIONS, SO THAT
SHOULD NOT ADD TO THE INFLATION
CONCERNS.
>> BECAUSE THE INFLATION PROBLEM
POTENTIALLY A HUGE PROBLEM, YOU
AND I REMEMBER THE JIMMY CARTER
ADMINISTRATION, HE LOST HIS BID
FOR REELECTION AS PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES IN PART
BECAUSE OF THE IRAN HOSTAGE
CRISIS BUT ALSO BECAUSE
INFLATION, HIGH INTEREST RATES
WERE REALLY DEVASTATING THE U.S.
AT THAT TIME.
>> INFLATION IS A REAL CONCERN
BUT WE SHOULD ALSO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT IS THAT REAL INFLATION
ACCOUNTED FOR WAGES FOR MANY
MANY WORKERS IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT HAS NOT GONE UP FOR ALMOST 50
YEARS.
PEOPLE ARE PAYING MUCH MORE THAN
THEY CAN AFFORD FOR CHILD CARE,
COLLEGE, HEALTH CARE, AND THIS
LEGISLATION BEGINS TO ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS